the big story of the last couple days is
that special counsel john durham who has
been investigating
whether trump had something to do with
russia or where some spying came from
and did hillary have anything to do with
it he dropped his report a couple days
ago so i'm going to read a bunch here
from the daily wire we tried to condense
it in a way to just give you enough to
get the bare bones facts out of this and
then we'll talk about it in just a sec
from the daily wire special counsel john
durham who is investigating the origins
of the fbi's trump russia probe says in
a new court filing that lawyers for the
clinton campaign paid a tech company to
infiltrate servers belonging to trump
tower and the trump white house in an
effort to establish a narrative linking
president donald trump to russia the
revelation was made in a court filing
late last week that centered on
potential conflicts of interest
connected to the representation of
former clinton campaign lawyer michael
sussman who has been charged with
allegedly lying to the fbi
the indictment against sussman says he
told then fbi general counsel james
baker in september of 2016
less than two months before the 2016
presidential election that he was not
doing work for any client when he
requested and held a meeting in which he
presented purported data and white
papers that allegedly demonstrated a
covert
communications channel between the trump
organization and alpha bank which has
ties to the kremlin
but durham's filing on february 11th in
a section titled factual background
reveals that sussman had assembled and
conveyed the allegations to the fbi on
behalf of at least two specific clients
including a tech executive
and a u.s based internet company and the
clinton campaign the filing says that
during the summer of 2016 the tech
executive worked with sussman an
investigative firm retained by a law
firm on behalf of the clinton campaign
and employees at tech companies to
gather
data the basic bones of it are that
durham now is alleging that they have
evidence that the clinton campaign in
essence was spying on computers that
were at trump tower
two months before the election and then
it sounds like it leaks into once trump
actually was president so let's continue
from the daily wire president joe
biden's campaign also hired the tech
firm that former secretary of state
hillary clinton alleged allegedly hired
to spy on former president donald trump
and link him to russia the biden
campaign paid nearly 20 thousand dollars
to a cyber security firm at the center
of special counsel john durham's
investigation into the origins of the
trump-russia probe the campaign paid new
star information services in 2020 for
accounting and compliance work according
to federal election commission records
according to durham nustar's chief
technology officer rodney joff
accessed sensitive web traffic data that
the company maintained on behalf of the
white house executive office in order to
collect derogatory information about
donald trump
jaffe allegedly provided the information
to hillary clinton campaign lawyer
michael sussman who in turn gave it to
the cia during a meeting in february
2017. durham charged sussman in
september with lying to the fbi about
his investigation of trump as ross noted
in the report the fact that biden paid
the same firm during the 2020
presidential election
also raises questions uh of whether or
not the firm was paid for the same type
of activity namely whether jaffe
continued snooping on trump in the most
recent
election
okay
i get it it's a lot but i think you can
sort of see it sounds like
it sounds like and the durham report
will be analyzed people are going to
continue looking at it it's going to be
ignored by mainstream media this is the
type of thing where if we had a
mainstream media that we could trust and
the durham report was dropped well the
mainstream media might cover it honestly
and say boy you know we actually have
covered it because we're fair and
impartial and we've debunked these you
know 10 points here or we found you know
three inconsistencies here et cetera et
cetera instead they're going to ignore
it because it kind of makes hillary look
a bit guilty so i think you sort of see
that in what we laid out right there now
we've got two clips this is karine
jean-pierre
and jen saki you know jen saki she's the
white house press secretary karine
jean-pierre is sort of her sidekick or
when when saki is out for the afternoon
or has a headache or just can't go to
work whatever it is she jumps in there
uh now they are actually being
questioned about this and uh surprise
surprise they don't want to talk about
it this news is about a durham
investigation
does the president have any concerns
about a candidate for president
using computer experts to infiltrate
computer systems
of competing candidates or even the
president-elect to you for the goal of
creating a narrative is that something
that
that's something i can't speak to from
this podium so i refer you to the
department of justice
in that report monitoring
internet traffic
is is that spying
again i can't speak to that report you i
i refer you to department of justice
generally speaking that with monitoring
internet trafficking
i refer you to department of justice i
can't speak to that from here there was
an outside company with ties to the
clinton camp uh monitoring server data
info on the executive office of the
president through the obama
administration possibly into the trump
administration uh do you know if there's
still a system picking up
server data on the eop and if not when
it stopped again i i know you asked my
colleague a few questions about this the
other day but i would point you any
questions about this at the department
of justice and then is what was
described in the filing there
monitoring internet traffic is that
generally speaking would that be
considered something
along the lines of spying again i would
point you to the department of justice
go ahead okay so obviously they're not
going to comment on this it's
interesting that they're referring
people to the department of justice
because i guess if the department of
justice starts getting asked questions
about this they might have to look into
it and they might find something that
they might not like so in essence just
to like really like in the most simplest
terms so if you're sitting at dinner
tonight and someone's asking you about
this or did you hear about that
nonsensical report in essence the durham
report is saying that hillary clinton's
campaign
paid a firm to spy on the servers at
trump tower when it was the office of
the president-elect and then potentially
into the administration and what now
links this to the current administration
is that the biden campaign used the same
firm in 2020. so i'm not going to sit
here and tell you that i know exactly
what this fully means and that hillary
was absolutely aware and everything else
but now do you see how when we had four
years of the media running around saying
that trump was compromised by the
russians and he was a russian spy or a
russian asset and that there were emails
back and forth then blah blah blah
do you think that maybe it had a little
something to do with this and does it
seem a little bit weird that the hillary
clinton campaign whether she knew it or
not
was paying a firm to spy on the
president-elect are we allowed to do
that here in the united states that is
exactly what durham is laying out he is
saying that the campaign the hillary
campaign paid this firm to do that and
then flash forward four years that the
biden campaign work with this same firm
we do need to know about this right like
we honestly do need to know about this
whether you fully believe it whether
that was sort of the the genesis of how
the media then decided to run around for
four years calling you know trump a
russian spy and all that stuff or not
it's like we do need to know what
happened here because otherwise how can
we ever have a transfer of power that's
going to make sense right like our
campaigns allowed to just spy on each
other set up you know software on
servers and all of those things